las vegas attorney arrested on lewd  discharges appeared in court today the 8  news now i-team learned last week  douglas crawford is accused of sexually  harassing his employees at his law  office in court today prosecutors allege  that crawford was also offering legal  services to clients in exchange for  sexual acts  they also said much of this was caught  on camera and it was well known among  his employees  it was so prolific in fact that metro  sent in an undercover officer a vice  detective and within 30 minutes of that  undercover officer who was pretending to  have a divorce case and giving him the  facts of that he was stroking her back  and attempting to kiss her  prosecutors say a handful of victims  have been identified but metro is  looking for more if you have any  information you can call metro or crime  stoppers meantime crawford's bail has  been set at 100 thousand dollars he is  due in court again in july